[Musique]
notre fille avec l'herbe odieux qui
questionne bergevin bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir m'asseoir gerald alors une
entente entre air canada et le
gouvernement fédéral fait longtemps
qu'on l'attendait depuis longtemps que
ça sonne négocier clair votre votre
réaction d'abord la première réaction
c'est vrai que ça fait six mois qu'on en
parle ou seat de gérald un oui lundi
soir au st enfin on va verser des sommes
j'ai la même question pourquoi westjet
transat air transat ou french lines ne
bénéficient pas de ce même genre
d'entente mais surtout bravo pour la
reprise des liens régionaux
ça faisait très mal aux régions cette
absence la paire canada que ce soit en
abitibi-témiscamingue sur la côte nord
aux îles de la madeleine ont le besoin
d'un lien fiable avec les autres villes
absolument et ça viendra peut-être en
faut dire sur west gate la négociation
était vraiment avec air canada ont dit
qu'on en amérique on négocier avec
chacun des compagnies aériennes et c'est
michael c'est bien le sous ministre aux
finances qui fait ça alors vous pensiez
quoi christiane de cette entente entre
air canada et ottawa ce soir c'est une
excellente nouvelle d'abord air canada
c'est un siège social dans la région de
montréal savez c'est pas une entreprise
comme les autres lignes aériennes
c'est une entreprise qui a qui génèrent
des bénéfices en temps normal
exceptionnelle la dernière année fiscale
avant la crise on
je n'arrive plus d'un point 6 milliards
en bénéfices des employés trente deux
mille personnes
imaginez tous les bénéfices indirects
pour beaucoup de petits fournisseurs
alors si la france a jugé bon de mettre
5 milliards dans air france klm pour
s'assurer 30 % de la propriété l'italie
de racheter alitalia pour garder sa
ligne aérienne
allemande d'investir chez lufthansa
c'était essentiel de venir depuis hier
canada qui a été très bien gérée par
kalin revenue secouer montréal et puis
je pense que c'est la première étape
quand on fait de la création il faut
commencer puis ensuite je crois que nos
autres lignes aériennes ça pourrait
suivre on n'est pas dans la
nationalisation ici on n'est pas dans la
recapitalisation comme on a vu en france
en italie
on est dans un prêt est ce que claire
c'est la bonne formule 1 près à air
canada
je pense que oui on se souvient qu air
canada était de propriété canadienne et
qu'elle a été privatisée dans le
contexte faire du retour en arrière
c'est peut-être pas une bonne idée
d'aller de l'avant avec un prêt ou des
prêts selon les différents secteurs
je pense que c'est la bonne solution
faut aussi réfléchir aux autres
compagnies aériennes le canada c'est le
site hier air canada devra aussi amener
une aide aux autres compagnies aériennes
il ne pourrait pas nationalisées ou
d'investir comme prêteur comme
partenaire dans toutes les compagnies
aériennes
alors je pense que c'est la bonne façon
de le faire à ce moment donc on parle
d'un prêt on parle d'un fonds pour
rembourser les billets annulés pour
toutes les compagnies aériennes et on
parle de restrictions aussi pour la
rémunération des dirigeants
question est ce que c'est la bonne
formule selon vous les clefs sans
connaître tous les détails ce sens en
une formule qui est approprié
on sait que michael sabia est un
excellent négociateur est effectivement
comme le disait qu est clair la
participation à l'équité ça amène
d'autres considérations air canada a
déjà appartenu au gouvernement
je pense que ce qui sera très important
celle ci qui prévues dans le clan ce
qu'on dit c'est de permettre la
continuation de l'achat de nouveaux
appareils
on sait que les lignes arrière non des
obligations pour la réduction du carbone
d'avoir une flotte moderne c'est
essentiel pour continuer les opérations
or il n'ya pas de doute pour moi que la
formule est bien pensé et je dirais que
pour moi si j'étais pour air transat est
la recette du gâteau a peut-être besoin
d'être modifié un peu parce que là
c'est pas les paramètres et les
fondamentaux sont pas décents malines
non effectivement et transats par
exemple pas tout à fait les mêmes
problèmes
donc point de presse dans 25 minutes on
va y revenir d'une émission à 24,60 ce
soir c'est à 19 heures heure de l'est
je vous emmène sur la firme internet si
tout se permettre
merci beaucoup
il ya aussi une aide qui sera accordée
aux aéroports locaux et régionaux
et ça aussi c'est appréciable c'est
parce qu'ils ont énormément souffert de
l'absence de voyageurs partout au pays
absolument bon c'est un bon point a
ajouté claire c'est correct je vous
amène sur un formulaire qui demande à la
ville de montréal dédommagement de 6
millions de dollars si le grand prix se
tient à huis clos cette année pour
compenser les pertes de revenus de
billetterie
christiane est ce qu'on doit est ce
qu'on doit dire oui à la fft on passe de
gros moteurs à gros moteur mais je suis
un peu plus tiraillée par cette question
c'est indéniable que le grand prix a
même des retombées économiques très
importantes et dans cet angle là c'est
une entreprise en plus de 87 millions de
téléspectateurs peut-être un autre 40
millions qui regarde ça sur les médias
sociaux
alors il ya une retombée et l'an dernier
y en a pas eu
c'est quand on regarde le coût des
redevances qui est plus de 17 millions
par année pour tenir l'événement on
contribue déjà beaucoup alors j'ai
hésité mais si on regarde ça dans une
optique d'aider des entreprises qui
amène une contribution à l'économie à
notre économie des retombées et au même
titre les internationaux du canada au
niveau du tennis pur d'être voudront
lever la main je crois que le montant
qui est requis c'est lé bien sûr
justifiée par les dépenses qu'ils sont
encore eu on devrait dire on devrait
dire oui on devrait dire le vrai et et
moi je dis non surtout pas la barre
c'est une entreprise privée on
soutiendrait financièrement un événement
en soi mais les principaux les
principales retombées
qu'ils s'adressent aux hôteliers aux
restaurateurs ne serait pas présente et
ses retombées
on se sent aussi que ces entreprises là
connaissent des défis majeurs depuis le
début de la pandémie
je trouverais vraiment dommage qu'on
investisse dans l'industrie de la f1
sans avoir accompagné adéquatement les
hôteliers les restaurateurs de tous les
secteurs
par ailleurs je me pose la question sur
la valeur d'une f1 quand on est en
pleine réflexion sur les changements
climatiques
ça revient toujours se questionne à
chaque fois qu'ils ont un petit
questionnaire ou un gros questionnement
ou un moyen questionnement sur la f1 on
se demande toujours si on a vraiment
besoin à montréal de garder cet
événement là je peux vous dire que quand
on voyage à travers le monde
montréal est connue notamment pour son
grand prix
et c'est vrai le point de clerc sur le
changement climatique mais les
manufacturiers investissent aussi dans
la transformation de leurs produits et
et comment pourrait-on se priver de
cette visibilité wii en europe en
personne cette année puis on aurait aimé
mieux avoir un grand prix à l'automne
on aurait pu voir la réponse des autres
on sait que du côté de imola en italie
du côté de l'angleterre ils vont décider
le 17 mai s'il y aura un grand prix en
personne ou pas puis d'une certaine
façon la décision sera rendue ici votre
servira à jouer à aider la formule 1 est
à demander les mêmes compensation mais
clé je pense que pour cette année de
maintenir le produit on a une relation
qui est quand même qui amène aussi l'eau
s'ils une visibilité et un tourisme est
un événement touristique incomparable et
madame plantes aujourd'hui 10e c'est ça
que j'essaie de retrouver mais madame
plantes aujourd'hui 10 est de toute
façon si ça ne si par exemple on le
passe cette année parce qu'on veut pas
donner de 6 millions que ça s'envoie si
je me trompe pas c'est la turquie qui
serait peut-être intéressés à le
présenter
mais ça serait pas annulée pour les
autres mais année d'après autrement dit
l'avenir de la f1 n'est pas un jeu clair
donc est ce que ça vaut est-ce que ça
vaut la peine de donner le 6 millions
cette année et je répète non et l'avenir
de la f1 n'est pas en jeu elle
cette compétition-là cette formule un
lors reviendra mais moi je me pose la
question sur le soutien à tous les
autres événements qui ceux qui sont en
difficulté qui requiert des visiteurs ou
des spectateurs pour bénéficier des
entrées d'argent un conte associé à ça
je me demande aussi l'impact qu'on donne
le message qu'on envoie le leadership
qu'on assume face à toutes les autres
activités dans toutes les régions toutes
les autres activités culturelles et
touristiques et d'attractivité
alors je répète pour moi c'est un non
est effectivement laisse reviendra
éventuellement bon alors c'est le duo 11
au 13 juin avec ou sans un spectateur
sur place on verra ce que ça va donner
et alors sans aide financière elle avait
requis son aide financière on verra
aussi les alentours les 87 millions de
spectateurs comment vous dire c'est 15 $
par spectateur 87 millions de
spectateurs si on met 6 millions de
dollars essentiellement ses 15 $ par
personne
c'est pas grave c'est pas grand chose vu
comme ça questionne merci beaucoup
claire merci vous également bon ça bonne
soirée